hello everybody and welcome to part 3 of
let's play nightmare house - I was gonna
take a break after the prologue but I
just had to get more into it it's happy
oh yeah oh yeah it was scare tastic
scare tactic
all right here oh my fellow inmates
nobody hi who are you security under
lockdown please remain calm and wait for
further assistance that's a good voice
actress hello anybody who nice art
that's art in my book anybody I'm so mad
I'll throw a chair take this with me
no no chairs are our first and last line
of defense
boink flashlight
all right radio security monitor Oh
switch bombed accept it totally meant
and what do we get
save me--save come on to help oh yes yes
I'm talking to you yes I hear you if you
want to get out of here
do exactly as I say no I know you have a
lot of questions not one now it's
absolutely vital they get here as
quickly as you can
I I don't want it I don't trust you you
aren't oh oh I like it now yeah into the
kitchen to find a surprise waiting for
either
you'll need it where where are the
weapons in the kitchen that makes sense
let me trust you because you magically
lock that door on me
why don't we got here Oh bring it on Oh
nobody again oh that guy's gone
he ran away so patiently escort security
and medical staff proceed to the cell
detention area immediately are they
talking about me what's it here blood Oh
boots oh he got sucked in the toilet
Oh all that was left was his shoes man
it's like that episode of table the
South Park I always put the lid down I
always put the lid down for my ladies
who's there
who wants some ah nobody again let me
recharge my flashlight
uh what was that whatever it was it
wasn't scary oh that's not my present
yay Gibby don't even try to get up don't
even try it
don't I'm talking to you the last zombie
that got up after I whacked his face
will get whacked for in the fest okay oh
you son of a [ __ ] you betrayed me
I trusted you all right no but that gone
zombies won't stay dead always obey the
rule to double tap Oh what was that
nothing yeah that's right open up you
knew what was good for you
Oh bring it on Oh who's there
nobody Hey I'm ready I'm so ready
talk to me you got markiplier song shot
my hacks you're a times a found its way
out here but you should consider it a
blessing what I mean you know is they're
down but you're going to need it well I
think I'd real pretty uglier you this
pleasant conversation thank you wow it's
not electronically controlled you're a
ghost voice in my head you're the little
girl's daddy this is a ghost ax+
to death killing ghosts oh what's that
light
[Music]
nope nope um oh no not puzzles everybody
no that's my worst enemy
Oh leave an epic jump oh nice job mark
thank you
oh damn it bad job all right
try off hockey take two oh wait oh yeah
what do I do
back missing something here
something Oh
push this oh yeah off so strong look at
me now I go that was a puzzle that a
two-year-old cassavetes still took you
500 something gonna be in the vents I
know it I know it
bring it on bring it on
oh sorry about this sorry about the
screen shake I know some of you don't
like it but I need that Oh what already
come into the blades of yes oh yeah
nothing this is a security checkpoint an
inspection is required on the seed pass
this area missiles and a wait the nearby
security staff this is a standard
procedure guess I can't use that
computer nothing
oh good for you just yeah when I get to
you you're gonna be - I saw that oh I
saw it
bring it on I'm coming for you yeah yeah
uh who's there
Oh after you [ __ ] wait baby
maybe we get a look good look at here
nope nope oh she's shy huh
intimidated by my handsomeness good
charms good luck charms and I'm good at
word talking apparently all right
chapter two already I'm ready
oh I'm so ready bring it on bring it oh
yeah oh well number two elevator gets
stuck no rule number three elevators
itself rule number one is is a monster
in one of these doors
number two is it falls and crashes rule
number three is it gets stuck so if this
is like a combo of all rules take it out
there we go
that one's so bad that's what it's
reverse rule number two ah okay cool all
right that's a fish
applause oh there goes my rule number
two lotion I like it all right Olivia oh
why don't you try next time I got a
shovel oh yeah these who are you nobody
that's who gas masks didn't you do you
much good couldn't even hide up your
ugliness Oh burn we're taking great care
to ensure the comfort and tranquility of
our patients language you can find a
vending machines and television sets in
all grading areas marked ohms mark are
you gonna get up better not burn uh-oh
I'm watching you huh
right Oh how about you you got no head
all right
legs don't get up none of you none of
you get up
none well get it drink ah you got up you
got up you broke the one rule all follow
the rule mi only though the only one
here that respects the rules sorry sorry
everybody
okay you're a ghost
[Music]
you are now entering the radiology
department AHA all cell phones and
electronic devices must be switched off
in the designated areas to avoid
interference with vital medical
equipment oh yeah these guys are trying
but it's not scaring me not even not
even a little bit yeah just cuz I'm a
saving ten billion times doesn't mean
I'm worried something's gonna happen oh
no oh no there we go oh oh who wants
some
Oh my flashlight doesn't work Oh too bad
someone crying
i'ma do some scare me Oh God alright
alright I gotta cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching I do
appreciate it and I will see you guys in
part four of let's play nightmare house
bye bye